[Music]
okay I'm going to need the R Train to
switch over to the express tracks at
34th
[Music]
Street nice
one unlock the door do it now or I'll
kill you everybody else this side
fishing the
trol Center call and peling
123 why'd you stop 123 you're all green
ahead ra control center do you read me
who is this this is a man who's going to
give the city a run for money now what
is the price for New York City hostages
this morning what do you think a million
a piece is too high oh I'm not a hostage
negotiator I'm a Civil Service employee
oh I think you'll do just fine now what
time do you got on your watch 213 59
minutes I'm going to start killing
passengers you don't want innocent
people dying do you you tell
me life is simple now you just have to
do what I say call the mayor now
somebody just hijacked P 123 you don't
think this was fate you and me you know
I'm just a guy I'm just a guy on the
other end of the mic I do like you man
you may be the last friend I ever
make how are you going to get the money
here they're sting down every
intersection from here to Brooklyn the
money's on the way look up
there was an accident now somebody else
has to die those cops are going to be
down that tunnel got an easy shot please
advise let them unload on me I want to
make you a deal I will trade you for all
these passengers you don't have to do
this they want me to take the money down
to the tunnel you do what you have to do
but we need milk so on your way home I
want you to bring a gallon I can get a
half a gallon I get a half a gallon
you're just like me armor no you use one
of these you got 5 Seconds
okay
we didn't know how the DAT was going to
start I know exactly how it was going to
start two yeah but do you know how it's
going to end
1 when I first met this woman I saw Rose
and I latched on to her I told her baby
I'm I don't want to marry I just want to
be your man Rose told me I told him if
he wasn't a man kind and move out the
way so the mar kind could find me that's
what she told me you're in my way you're
blocking the view move out the way so I
can find me a
husband whereit Cory I want him to help
me with this
fence he got recruited by a college
football team it ain't going to get him
nowhere if he be like you in the sports
he going to be all right ain't but two
men ever play baseball good as you and
where it ever get me I ain't got a pot
to piss in or a window to throw it out
of hey pop can I ask you a question how
come you ain't never like me what law is
there say I got to like you a man is
supposed to take care of his family you
live in my house fill your belly with my
food put you behind on my bed because
you're my son now don't you go through
life worrying about whether somebody
like you or not you best be making sure
they're doing right by
you
Cory just trying to fill out your shoes
I don't want him to be like me I want
him to get as far away from my life as
he possibly can get you the only decent
thing ever happened to me Rose you can't
be nobody but who you are Troy that's
all you got to measure yourself against
the world out
there Rose I got something to tell you I
don't know how to tell you this why Dy
why you ought to know it's time I don't
want to no Dam
it what you ever giving me your feet
Them Bones that pumping ho you never
done nothing but hold me back afraid I
was going to be better than
you everything that boy do he do for
you it's not easy for me to admit that
I've been standing in the same place for
18 years well I've been standing with
you I got a life too don't you think I
had dreams and hopes what about my life
what about
me what you want to
do some people build fences to keep
people out and other people build fences
to keep people
[Music]
[Applause]
in
seconds that's what I'll give you to
decide your
[Music]
fate Roberto Roberto tell me what did
you do back
home government work I'm retired now for
you what always St my
bny because of these people I'm
beginning to understand real peace oh
and I'm starting to
believe this is where I'm supposed to
be what happens here happens you many
times the
mafia they like cancer no
cure should stay out of other people's
business whatever it is you and your
friends do do it somewhere else you
warning me I'm preparing is that a time
mix no it's a boo that's the median
nerve that I'm
compressing that's a level three you
don't want it to go to a level
four you seem like a man who understands
violence I like this place you can't
take that from
me I can take anything I want
police found multiple dead bodies on
that farm in Sicily did you kill
[Music]
him 9
seconds do I look like a
[Music]
killer
you know him didn't you then you had
that one little
feeling but you waved it
away you should have listened to that
one little
feeling just like I'm listening to you
now you can talk to
me I'm all a friend you
got you're not exactly a department
Favorite Things probably changed a lot
since he left you still got to catch him
right yeah not that much of change then
right I can assure you all we are taking
a 24/7 all handson deck approach to
these
cases gu's a shark if he stops he dies
he likes to drive probably has a decent
car maybe two high
mileage he must really like my car I do
how's the trunk
space
something I got to know as a guy with
the best clearance raid in the
department work 15 years without a
promotion maybe I didn't go to the right
church when I look in your eyes what I
see it Ain
[Music]
good he knew all the details but he
wasn't within 10 miles of the killing
why he that why is
that
[Music]
how's the trunk
space what do you want I want to nail
the bastard for who for all of the girls
he
[Music]
killed I want to nail him
too difference is I'm doing it for
[Music]
me it's little things Jimmy
it's the little things that rip you
apart it's the little things
that get you
[Music]
caught 30 Winters ago the war tore a
hole in the sky
only a few
survived our only hope is in my
hands take off the pack nice and slow
put that hand on me again you won't get
it
back curs it be the ground for our
sake for out of the ground we were taken
and to the dust we shall return
I told you you weren't going to get that
back there's a little town just the
beginning all we need is that book he's
different than the others you're not
going to be able to make him do what you
want him to do this is your last chance
give it up or I swear I'll bury you I
don't want any trouble that's too
bad nobody touches it but me you
understand
me I love this guy
here
please teach
me put a crew together we're going
after go back
[Music]
inside
it's not book there no
[Music]
weapon
man Carries a Gun he tends to use
it Dan you dead pity I had just ordered
a drink from that man man took a job
looking for some man to join me is it
difficult
impossible how many you got so far you
and
me who's she we work for
her good Lord that's right that man
murdered my husband I want something I
take
it he will take everything we have so
you seek revenge I seek righteousness
but I'll take revenge I need more than a
few to help us fight what a bunch of
Misfits we are you know how to shoot
that thing I'm good so am
I good Lu my friend oh we're good we got
a
Mexican I sense we are
[Music]
bonding
we got a seven he's got an
army and they'll be murdered by the
world's greatest
lover why are you here fighting someone
else's fight these people deserve their
lives back just make sure we're fighting
the battle in front of us not a battle
behind every man got the right to choose
where he
dies we have nowhere else to go
so you a't never seen a soldier like me
one 2 three I'm a vigilante 4 56 kiss
that ass goodbye when I pull the gun
then somebody got to
die what's the plan I've always wanted
to blow something up that's not a
plan how' we do I think we killed them
all
oh good morning Trina good morning
Captain Whitaker here's a manifest with
102 Souls on board let's get them tucked
in we're ready to
[Music]
push how you feeling man look like you
pulled some kind of move up there man
you saved a lot of lives
that's we are in a dive I have no
control on my side we going everybody
Embrace positions the way you landed
that plane was nothing short of a
miracle I see nothing but hous listen to
me trim us nose down plane fell apart at
30,000 ft we're going to roll it what
what do you mean roll it ready here we
[Music]
go I'm on list baby girl there is
there's all kinds of crazy news people
out here you're a rockar man you will
never pay for another drink as long as
you live Captain Whitaker is a real
American hero this is h l he's an
attorney from Chicago why do we need a
lawyer you don't remember having your
blood drawn the night of the crash you
had alcohol in your system that could be
life in
prison the ntsp he in 10 days under the
microscope right now are you hiding
something going to shoot me can I come
inside yeah come on inside I'll shoot
you inside this was an act of God those
God would do this our investigators
concluded the aircraft failed the FAA
plac 10 pilots and simulators recreated
the event every pilot killed everybody
on board you were the only one who could
do
it you saved my
mom I want to talk about the day is
leading up to the accident this thing is
so heavy it's killed
me I drank the night before for the
flight does wha know he's going to jail
my clients don't go to jail it's a lie
it's a
alive I'm trying to save your life my
life we lost the
power bra for impact no one could have
landed that plane like I
[Music]
did I'm will Coulson we're working
together today at train
1206 is there a problem I just don't
like working at a damn daycare center I
don't like working at a retirement home
so all
right this ain't training in training
they just give you an F out here you get
killed mared s up it's a long story how
about you you mared got two beautiful
daughters have fun what do we do when we
get to a railroad crossing
fing
we have an unmanned train rolling into a
highly populated area with no air brakes
yeah 66 what's up there's an unman train
on the Northbound track he's under power
he's coming straight at us what are we
worried about in terms of cargo eight
Great Cars of hazardous chemicals we're
not just talking about a train we're
talking about a missile the size of the
Chrysler Building I need to know where
that train is we're not exactly sure
you're not sure we'll find out what
it gets worse I've got 150 students
coming in on some field trip on track 16
training that size going that fast
vaporize anything in front of it we have
been told to anticipate an event radius
20 to 45 miles the only way to stop that
kind of power grab it by the tail gun in
the opposite
direction are you in or you out you want
to kill yourself you do it alone all
right you do what you
want
wait I'm not risking us company just
because some engineer wants want to play
Hero not for
you not doing it for
you this is RO Co and your
conductor we're going to run this
[Music]
down tell your sister I love you
home the train is increasing in speed
we're going to be coming in too hot just
lost our
breaks hey
close your eyes if you want you got a
real neck for inspiring confidence you
know
that my name is Dalton Russell pay
strict attention to what I say because I
choose my words carefully and I never
repeat myself recently I planned and set
in motion events to execute the perfect
bank robbery everybody get down on the
floor
no why because I
can are you the hostage negotiator
that's right detective Fraser this
detective Mitchell what do you got put
on one of these suits and these masks we
got to step back and look at this thing
from a distance things are not all they
appear to
be back up back up one jumbo jet with
full gas tank and Pilots at JFK parked
in the runway we give you till 9:00 p.m.
to do this then we'll kill one hostage
every hour till I talk to them to get
nothing not even a cup of
coffee get those people up the straet
your honor you know about this hostage
situation what's it to do with you well
I need to be assured that certain
interests are protected just let
everybody stay calm okay don't I sound
calm to you yes you do look detective
there are matters at stake here that are
a little bit above your pay grade why
don't you just tell a me to raise my pay
grade to the right level problem
solved this goes down wrong they're
going to dump this whole mess in your
your lap meet me at the front door you
got to be crazy to go in there like a
fox tenzo Washington whoever heard of
bank robbers escaping on a plane with 50
hostages I think you're stalling why I
don't know clyve Owen when I said that I
planned the perfect bank robbery I meant
precisely that and Jody Foster I can
change your entire program so the sooner
that you stop being my problem the
better off you'll be they heard
everything we said they bugged us keep
your men back you planned every inch of
this thing right from the start you got
everybody marching to your beat
including me and I'm through buying it
what are you doing come on this ain't no
bank
robbery Inside
[Music]
Man Mr Ramirez was told he was not under
arrest and yet he was refused use of the
bathroom that's violation of civil
rights you can wait and address this a
trial oh I would like to address it now
I'm just saying Mr Israel if guards in
this courtroom would not allow you to
use the bathroom you would by all
definition be detained I'm going to hold
you in contempt if you continue to
pursue this you're asking me to obey an
erroneous Court decision you tell me to
wait in my experience wait okay fin you
in
[Music]
contempt volary manslaughter it's a good
deal it's an enema of sunshine sorry for
taking a nan off of your assembly line
rubber stamp
existence hello everybody looking at you
crazy Israel talk about what to expect
if you are arrested we're going to rap I
don't mean hip-hop I'm sorry why had a
sister standing in a brother sitting as
gendered and sexist and and polite and
patronizing and
polite this Law Firm has run a deficit
for
years you're firing
me you were your Cornerstone of activism
you're inspiring I'm tired of doing the
impossible for The
[Music]
Ungrateful you got to make a
living take care of yourself I
am I know where CJ's hold up what's that
worth a lot don't tell nobody everything
we discuss will be
confidential the man who did it I know
where he is I want the reward
cash
the world is full of wonderful things
what do you think I'm got I move
in I just took something about you from
a solid Source you knew where I was God
I got you anytime I want God these are
dangerous
people ran I'm concerned about
you I went last
night I've been deal with de since you
don't just walk away from this
I'm
walk I can finish
this each one of us is greater than the
worst thing we've ever
[Music]
done you ever heard the saying never rob
a bank across from a diner that has the
best donuts in Three Counties that's not
a same yes it is no it's not I get what
saying it's not the same it is the same
it's the same now
go everybody sit down on the floor
fire let's go come
on how much you figure 40 million $40
million but I got bad news for
[Music]
you what is that is that a badge in your
hand
DEA bet officer Michael stigman you know
Bobby beans was DEA
man your boy stick's a piece of work did
you know he was special forces you've
been on this LMP way too
long pull over did you miss
me all right all right on the count of
three we'll let each other go all one
yeah two three that ain't making me not
be able to trust you the bank was a
setup we got to figure out whose money
that was well like we're working
together no not like we working no like
we're working in the same vicinity
together in the same area cod
[Applause]
together he ripped off the
CIA where's the money it ain't down
there I can guarantee you
that must of way out here got 24 hours
to bring me the
moneyer so bu what's your plan I got a
plan I mean I'm capable of coming up I'm
not saying you're not capable I'm just
saying you haven't told me what is it
I'm working on it yeah screw
it was your plan no one expected you
should have seen your
face you sure you can trust this
guy who they oh yesterday I said they
were my family today they kind of want
to kill me I understand the
feeling what I ever do to you besides
shoot me
great time's
over have I properly incentivized you
more than you know Make It
Rain you're my people and there's a Cod
you fight for the guy that's fighting
next to
you give me the keys you want them come
get them oh man what's unall for give me
the
keys you saw that move coming that's
correct give me the
[Music]
keys hi e for Ezekiel Rollins La was a
world of sunshine and
shadows hey easy how you doing baby
junor take easy on upstairs black and
white we got no work here sorry pH my
name's not pH
my name is Ezekiel
Rollins so here you need a job what kind
of work you do I'm just looking for
somebody D mon fiance at Todd Carter she
been gone 2 weeks see dney has a pred
elction for the company of
negroes he thought he knew how to play
the game any of y'all seen a white girl
by the name of Dalia Delia something
like that her name is stff you can't get
none of that tonight you know until he
stepped into a world why don't you tell
me about your friend dad tell woman
ain't good enough for you no more huh
where there are no rules why you
arresting me what time did you leave
grety James house this morning what is
going on she's not going to be waking up
Ezekiel he's looking for a woman no one
wants found was there anyone with you a
young lady named Dean Monet perhaps the
incumbent mayor the chief of police
close personal friends of mine then they
can help us find him no they can't and
getting in deeper than he ever expected
uh this is daany Monae you're looking
for me
I don't know if I should think of you as
a friend or as a private dick surrounded
by lies you can't trust me Mr Rollins I
am the next mayor and luckily for you A
friend of the Negro seduced by power
unless I give the cops a killer by
tomorrow morning I'm going to jail easy
Rollins is searching not very smart
talking about Mr Carter's business
there's too much going on for me to give
a damn about what you think is smart for
the truth who killed him I don't know
don't lie to me start up my car keep it
hot I'm coming out fast let's go get
herur don't shoot him we going to the
pool yeah why don't you scream
huh from the academy award-winning
producers of Philadelphia and the
Silence of the
Lambs Academy Award winner Denzel
Washington Devil in a Blue
Dress A Carl Franklin
film by the breing of my
thumbs Something Wicked This Way
Comes My Husband King that shall
[Music]
be if we should
fail we
[Music]
fail did thou not hear
noise he thought I heard a voice cry
sleep no
[Music]
more are you a man a and a bold one that
Dad look upon that which might app the
devil
I have no words my voice is in my
sword he was one of the most brilliant
CIA operatives we ever had until he went
rogue he responsible for the deaths of
multiple
agents this guy's just not going to walk
into an American Consulate without good
reason so lot new in Cape
Town I heard a slot open up one slot 37
applicants every one of them with more
field experience than you how am I
supposed to get more experience I'm
staring at Four Walls all
day this is won we're the last minute
reservation oh my
God that's toen Frost kill all the
surveillance cameras in this
room is this
[Music]
legal go go go go remember rule number
one you are responsible for your house
guest I'm your house guest they're here
for me but they want me alive you
they'll kill time are
wasting tick tock tick tock tick tock
tick tock heyy get in you serious yeah
get in the
truck the safe house has been
compromised follow protocol protocol
there's no protocol for
this who's after us and why I think you
need to consider how your safe house was
attacked in the first place P house was
a secure
location whoever crashed it they were
inv
someone told them someone you know
you're not going to get my head I'm
already in your
head Flor blood
stain so they're working
together I think W's turn I'm not your
only enemy
tonight you can stay blind or you can
open your
eyes
I'm taking you in I want you to take me
[Music]
in